[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes de métropole de
l'outre-mer et de l'étranger la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons cette
épidémie de kobe 19 dure depuis
maintenant plus d'un an un an de peine
des preuves vous nous aurons été au
moins quatre millions et demi a
contracté la maladie et où bientôt cent
mille familles auront été endeuillée un
an d'efforts pour tous d'angoise de
sacrifice de fierté aussi et d'actes
héroïques un an ou ensemble nous avons
résisté et a pris nous avons obtenues je
vous l'avais dit dès le début nous
allions vivre avec le virus
et c'est bien cela alors si ce soir je
m'adresse à vous avec autant d'humilité
que de détermination
c'est pour vous dire que nous allons
tenir encore essayé de faire le point
sur l'épidémie
les prochaines étapes essayez de vous
dire que si nous restons unis solidaires
si nous savons durant les prochaines
semaines nous organiser alors nous
verrons le bout du tunnel et nous nous
retrouverons si je m'adresse à vous ce
soir c'est pour appeler à la
mobilisation de chacun pour ce mois
d'avril où beaucoup se joue
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui après un
confinement dur lors de la première
vague au printemps 2020 puis ce qu'on a
appelé un confinement adapté lors de la
seconde vague à l'automne dernier nous
avons opté depuis le début de cette
année 2021 pour une réponse qui visaient
à freiner l'épidémie sans nous confiner
trois principes n'ont cessé de nous
guider
d'abord la sécurité vous protégez ne
jamais transiger sur la santé des
françaises et des français
permettre à chacun d'être soignés dans
les meilleures conditions
ensuite le deuxième principe c'est l'
équilibre
c'est à dire prendre en compte les
conséquences aussi des restrictions sur
nos enfants et leur éducation sur
l'économie la société
la santé mentale notamment des plus
jeunes
veillez à ne pas pénaliser les
territoires où le virus circule - ou peu
et puis le troisième principe c'est la
responsabilité
c'est à dire faire confiance préférer
aux contraintes pour tous le civisme de
chacun pour avoir les bons comportements
face au virus
limiter ses contacts se faire tester aux
premiers symptômes et s'isoler lorsqu'on
est positif sécurité équilibre
responsabilité ce sont ces trois
principes qui nous ont conduits fin
janvier à privilégier le renforcement de
cette stratégie tester alerte et
protéger le couvre-feu la fermeture de
certains établissements sur leur
confinement général du pays
nous avons tous consenti des efforts
importants et le virus a continué de
circuler il circule encore aujourd'hui
fortement
mais là où beaucoup de nos voisins ont
décidé de confiner il y a maintenant
quatre mois
nos voisins allemands par exemple là où
nos amis italiens en sont à leur
quatrième confinement nous avons aussi
par ses choix collectifs que nous avons
fait gagner des jours précieux de
liberté des semaines d'apprentissage
pour nos enfants
nous avons permis à des centaines de
milliers de travailleurs de garder la
tête hors de l'eau sans jamais perdre le
contrôle de l'épidémie
nous avons donc je le crois bien fait
croire en la responsabilité des français
ça n'est jamais un pari ces dernières
semaines nous faisons face à une
nouvelle donne depuis
au fond les premiers jours du mois nous
sommes entrés dans une course de vitesse
d'un côté le déploiement de la
vaccination qui permet d'espérer
raisonnablement une sortie de crise et
je vais y revenir et de l'autre la
propagation dans toute l'europe d'une
nouvelle forme de virus
ce variant qui a été identifiée pour la
première fois chez nos voisins
britanniques qu'à la fin de l'année
dernière et qui en quelque sorte a fait
apparaître une épidémie
dans l'épidémie celle ci est plus
étendue qu'au printemps dernier ce qui
fait qu'aucune région métropolitaine
n'est désormais épargner et celle ci est
aussi plus dangereuse qu'à l'automne ce
qui fait que le virus est plus
contagieux mais aussi plus meurtrier
les services de réanimation ont à
prendre en charge des personnes en bonne
santé qui ont aujourd'hui 60 ans même 50
ans quelques-uns parfois plus jeunes
retenez un chiffre 44 % des patients en
réanimation ont aujourd'hui moins de 65
ans face à ce double phénomène
nous avons décidé le 18 mars de prendre
pour près de 20 départements des
restrictions complémentaire au
couvre-feu national qui était déjà en
vigueur
deux semaines après la mise en place de
ces mesures les chiffres sont clairs oui
cette stratégie a eu des premiers effets
mais très clairement ces efforts restent
trop limité au moment où l'épidémie
accélère en quelque sorte
nous sommes en train de subir cette
accélération à cause du variant qui
risque de nous faire perdre contrôle si
nous ne bougeons pas nous devons donc
nous fixer pour les mois à venir un
nouveau cadre pour cela il ne faut
absolument pas céder à la panique
nous avons conservé la maîtrise de la
situation à l'hôpital
cette situation est dure beaucoup de
services sont surchargés mais nous n'en
avons pas perdu le contrôle nous ne
devons pas non plus céder au déni ce
serait faux de dire que si nous ne
faisions rien les choses
s'amélioreraient d'elle même nom alors
nous nous placerions dans une situation
délicate de potentiel saturation de tout
le pays aussi pour continuer à protéger
la vie au présent c'est à dire les
malades et pour protéger la vie au futur
c'est à dire nos enfants nous devons
pour les mois à venir
fournir chacun un effort supplémentaire
c'est cela ce que je nous demandent
collectivement ce sourds
un effort des soignants d'abord pour
augmenter nos capacités en réanimation
je veux ce soir salué à nouveau en votre
nom à tous l'action remarquable de nos
soignants et en particulier des équipes
de réanimation et de soins critiques qui
est secteur public comme secteur privé
agissent main dans la main mutualisent
les équipes innove
non seulement pour soigner les 28
malades du code vide à l'hôpital mais
aussi pour transformer des salles
d'opération en salle de réanimation pour
assurer une continuité de soins pour les
patients atteints de maladies graves
comme le cancer pour tous les moyens
d'urgence faire en sorte que tous les
reçoivent
et que tous puissent avoir les soins
dont ils ont besoin
en mars dernier à cette heure ci nous
les applaudit sion
n'oublions pas que depuis un an ils sont
sur le pont sans relâche pour augmenter
encore le nombre de personnes pouvant
être accueillis en réanimation centraux
des programmes et ils sont et seront
appuyés dans les prochains jours par des
renforts supplémentaires le nombre de
lits en réanimation a déjà été porté à 7
milles et je veux ici remercié les
étudiants en médecine les retraités le
service de santé des armées tous les
volontaires de la réserve sanitaire
tous sont mobilisés seront mobilisés de
manière accrue pour porter dans les
prochains jours notre capacité à un peu
plus de dix mille et en particulier
aussi avec l'ouverture de nouvelles
capacités d'accueil dans certains
hôpitaux parisiens deuxième effort qui
nous concerne tous celui ci les règles
qui sont en vigueur dans les dix neuf
départements en vigilance renforcée ces
règles seront étendues à tout le
territoire métropolitain
dès ce samedi soir et pour quatre
semaines
si nous faisons ce choix qui ne concerne
pas du territoire d'outre-mer ce
territoire où le virus circule moins et
territoires qui d'ailleurs pour certains
ont fait de très gros efforts il ya
plusieurs semaines pour ralentir aussi
le virus de leur côté si nous faisons ce
choix douché tout le territoire
métropolitain
c'est parce que plus aucune région
métropolitaine n'est aujourd'hui épargné
partout le virus circule vite de plus en
plus vite et par tous les
hospitalisations augmente et donc chacun
doit veiller non pas à s'enfermer
mais à limiter au maximum les contacts
les rencontres les moments de proximité
avec d'autres personnes
très concrètement ça veut dire que le
couvre-feu à 19 heures sera maintenue
par tous le télétravail qui est sans
doute la mesure la plus efficace
le télétravail sera systématisé et
j'appelle tous les travailleurs et tous
les employeurs à y avoir recours à
chaque fois qu'ils le peuvent
les commerces seront fermés tous les
territoires métropolitains
selon la liste déjà défini dans les
dix-neuf départements aujourd'hui
concerne nos citoyens qui souhaitent
changer de région pour aller s'isoler
pourront le faire durant ce week-end de
pâques les françaises et les français de
l'étranger qui veulent rentrer en france
pourront aussi le faire à tout moment et
nous ferons tout pour faciliter les
trajets et le quotidien de nos
concitoyens travailleurs
transfrontaliers
alors certains militent et je le sais
pour le retour généralisé de
l'attestation comme en mars 2020 nous
n'avons pas retenu cette option parce
que l'irresponsabilité de quelques-uns
ne doit pas ruiner les efforts de tous
les contrôles les sanctions seront
renforcés sur la voie publique pour
limiter les régler rassemblement parce
que c'est là que le danger existe et
pour encadrer la consommation d'alcool
mais très clairement nous faisons le
choix de la confiance
nous faisons le choix de la
responsabilité et si je puis dire de la
respiration
l'attestation ne sera donc obligatoire
en journée que pour les déplacements au
delà de 10 km du domicile en cette
période qui est marquée par de
nombreuses fêtes religieuses
je sais aussi pouvoir compter sur vous
afin d'éviter comme nous avons su le
faire à noël
rassemblement privé les fêtes avec les
amis la famille les proches
j'insiste vraiment sur ce point 7
lors de ces occasions que nous nous
contamine ont le plus il faut donc faire
cet effort fait un effort pour vous
protéger et pour protéger les autres
s'agissant des écoles et c'est quelque
sorte le troisième effort que nous
allons faire dans les semaines qui
viennent
s'agissant des écoles nous devons tous
être conscients de nos devoirs vis-à-vis
de notre jeunesse nous pouvons nous
féliciter dans notre pays d'avoir
réouvert parmi les premiers nos écoles
au printemps dernier le 11 mais
rappelez-vous et de les avoir maintenus
ouverte depuis septembre 2020 faisons
partie des rares pays qui ont fait ce
choix alors même que nous avons été très
frappé par l'épidémie
nous l'avons fait en conscience parce
que nous croyons dans cet investissement
dans les jeunes enfants les adolescents
quelle éducation parce que c'est le
combat du siècle qui s'ouvre
car nos enfants ont besoin d'apprendre
d'être ensemble et nul ne sait dire les
conséquences profondes et durables d'une
fermeture prolongée des écoles qui
renforce les inégalités sociales comme
les inégalités de destin alors oui le
virus circule dans les établissements
scolaires n'est pas plus qu'ailleurs et
l'éducation de nos enfants elle n'est
pas négociable l'école n'est pas
négociable
c'est pourquoi nous devons prendre nos
responsabilités oui il faut freiner le
virus aussi nous allons fermer durant
trois semaines les crèches les écoles
les collèges et délice mais oui nous
devons préserver l'éducation et
l'apprentissage
c'est pour cela que le calendrier
scolaire sera adapté pour ne pas laisser
nos enfants
seul et sans apprendre de manière très
concrète cela signifie que la semaine
prochaine
les cours pour les écoles collèges et
lycées
se feront à la maison sauf comme au
printemps 2020 pour les enfants des
soignants et de quelques autres
professions qui seront accueillis de
même que les enfants en situation de
handicap qui doivent continuer à pouvoir
être accueillis dans le secteur médico
social
les deux semaines suivantes soit à
partir du 12 avril
la france entière quelle que soit la
zone de vacances sera placée en vacances
de printemps
la rentrée aura donc lieu pour tous le
26 avril
physiquement pour les maternelles et les
primaires à distance pour les collèges
les lycées le 3 mai les collégiens et
les lycéens pourront retrouver
physiquement leur établissement le cas
échéant avec des jauges adapté je serai
croyez moi ce que cette réorganisation
implique de changement profond pour les
parents d'élèves et pour les familles
mais c'est la solution la plus adaptée
pour freiner le virus tout en préservant
l'éducation et donc l'avenir de nos
enfants
les étudiants quant à eux pourront pour
ceux qui le souhaitent continuer durant
toute cette période à se rendre à
l'université pour une journée de cours
par semaine
je veux ce soir en votre nom
remercier et saluer tous nos enseignants
et avec tous nos enseignants d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des personnels qui permettent
d'accueillir nos enfants dans les écoles
les collèges les lycées dans les
établissements spécialisés aussi car si
la france est un des pays à avoir le
moins fermer ses écoles comme je vous le
disais 42 semaines d'ouverture parfois
deux ou trois fois plus que certains de
nos voisins
c'est grâce à elle enfin comme depuis un
an
l'accompagnement économique et social
sera au rendez vous les parents qui
devront garder leur enfant et ne peuvent
pas télétravail et auront droit au
chômage partiel et pour les salariés les
commerçants les indépendants les
entrepreneurs et les entreprises tous
les dispositifs actuellement en vigueur
seront prolongées
je sais combien les efforts que je vous
demande sont difficiles je mesure ce
qu'ils emportent de conséquences pour
notre pays et pour vos vies et vous
savez aussi que nous avons tout fait
pour prendre ses décisions le plus tard
possible
et au moment où elle devenait
strictement nécessaire c'est maintenant
mais je tiens en même temps à vous dire
ce soir que grâce à la vaccination
la sortie de crise se dessine enfin
parce que oui à cette heure vous êtes
déjà plus de huit millions et demi à
avoir reçu une première injection de
vaccin 3 millions à en avoir reçu 2 et
le vaccin est efficace il est au bout de
quinze jours après l'injection de la
deuxième dose la meilleure preuve
d'ailleurs de cette efficacité
elle est dans les chiffres vous voyez à
cet instant à votre écran et dans la
mortalité en particulier de nos
concitoyens de plus de 80 ans qui ont la
mortalité qui a très fortement diminué
la meilleure preuve elle en est
d'ailleurs dans la situation des
résidents des maisons de retraite qui
vacciner à plus de 90% ont pu
progressivement reprendre une vie
normale
notre enjeu principal aujourd'hui c'est
donc d'accélérer encore et encore cette
mobilisation c'est celle évidemment du
gouvernement de nous tous et de tous les
soignants là encore avec une stratégie
claire d'abord continuer à avoir de plus
en plus de doses en accélérant nos
achats et surtout en produisant en
france et en europe
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés il y a
eu des retards
il y a eu des choses que nous avons
corrigé
je pourrais revenir mais dans les
semaines à venir nous allons encore
accélérer le nombre de doses que nous
obtenons et nous allons progressivement
devenir le premier continent au monde en
termes de production de vaccins c'est
construire notre indépendance c'est
garantir que s'il faut des doses
supplémentaires
nous ne dépendrons plus des autres c'est
garantir aussi la production de
nouveau vaccin s'il y avait à nouveau à
l'automne hiver ou l'année prochaine des
nouvelles vaccination à prévoir ensuite
c'est vacciner le plus vite possible
tous ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
c'est à dire les plus âgés les plus
fragiles ceux qui ont le plus de risques
de développer des formes graves et
j'assume totalement
cette priorité cet ordre que nous avons
donnée parce que c'est la garantie de
notre efficacité
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons soulager
plus rapidement l'hôpital
c'est ainsi que nous sauveront des vies
à partir de là nous mettons tous les
moyens pour vacciner vacciner vacciner
sans répit cent jours fériés le samedi
et le dimanche comme la semaine pour les
vaccins pfizer et moderna qui nécessite
des conditions de conservation
spécifiques
il y à 1700 centres de vaccination qui
ont ouvert notamment grâce à
l'engagement exemplaire de nos mères que
je veux ici remercier une fois encore
pour les vans pour les vaccins
astrazeneca et demain johnson & johnson
tous les médecins généralistes
pharmaciens infirmiers et infirmières
sont mobilisés
au total 250 mille professionnels
médecins pharmaciens sapeurs pompiers
infirmiers vétérinaires sont aujourd'hui
prêts à contribuer à ce grand effort
national
si vous avez plus de 55 ans et être
atteint par exemple de diabète
d'hypertension ou de surpoids
vous pouvez aujourd'hui prendre rendez
vous auprès de votre médecin votre
infirmer votre pharmacien qui vous
vaccinera directement avec le vaccin
astrazeneca
cela a commencé depuis la semaine
dernière et nous allons accélérer à
mesure que les doses seront livrés les
1700 centres ouverts sont à disposition
pour eux vacciner avec les vaccins de
pfizer et moderna est aujourd'hui
vacciner donc tous nos concitoyens qui
ont plus de 70 ans
les vaccinant les vaccinations sont en
cours et elles accélèrent partout je
sais
que beaucoup de nos aînés ont essayé de
prendre rendez vous pour se faire
vacciner ces dernières semaines trop
souvent sans succès et j'en suis
profondément désolé ce n'est pas
acceptable
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à
l'assurance maladie de mobiliser des
équipes pour y remédier depuis quelques
jours si vous avez plus de 75 ans vous
avez peut-être déjà reçu des appels car
l'ensemble des plus de 75 ans qui n'ont
pas réussi à obtenir un rendez-vous
seront appelés par nos services
pour pouvoir leur fixer et en parallèle
un numéro spécial sera mis à disposition
pour prendre un rendez-vous à partir du
16 avril
les premiers rendez vous seront accordés
aux personnes qui ont entre 60 et 70 ans
à partir du 15 mai les premiers
rendez-vous seront ouverts pour nos
concitoyens qui ont entre 50 et 60 ans
et à partir de la mi juin
les rendez-vous seront ouverts à
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français de moins de 50 ans une
stratégie de vaccination spécifique sera
par ailleurs prévu pour toutes les
professions les plus exposés en
particulier nos enseignants que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure mais aussi nos
forces de l'ordre et plusieurs autres
nous tiendrons l'objectif que je nous ai
fixé à savoir que d'ici à la fin de
l'été tous les français de plus de 18
ans qui le souhaitent pourront être
vaccinés
parce que c'est la clé pour renouer avec
la vie la clé pour ouvrir notre pays mes
chers compatriotes les efforts d'avril
d'une part et le déploiement de la
vaccination d'autre part c'est cette
taille qui va nous permettre de contenir
progressivement ce nouveau virus
cette tenaille qui va nous permettre à
partir de la mi mai deux commencé à
rouvrir progressivement le pays a
retrouvé cette culture qui nous a tant
manqué à retrouver les lieux de
rencontre les commerces à retrouver cet
art de vivre à la française que sont les
restaurants les cafés que nous aimons
tant
je reviendrai vers vous prochainement
pour préciser un agenda de réouverture
et pour que chacun puisse aussi se
projeter avec plus de visibilité dans
les mois qui viennent dès la mi mai nous
recommencerons à ouvrir avec des règles
strictes certains lieux de culture nous
autoriserons sous conditions l'ouverture
de terrasses et nous allons bâtir entre
la mi mai et le début de l'été un
calendrier de réouverture progressive
pour la culture le sport les loisirs
l'événementiel nos cafés et restaurants
mais d'ici là je sais pouvoir compter
sur vous mes chers compatriotes je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de lassitude de
fatigue je sais qu'il ya aussi parfois
de l'énervement de l'emportement et
c'est bien normal
je sais qu'à chaque étape de cette
épidémie
nous pourrions nous dire que nous
aurions pu faire mieux
nous avons commis des erreurs tout cela
est vrai
je sais une chose nous avons tenu nous
avons appris et nous nous sommes à
chaque fois améliorée alors oui
aujourd'hui pour le mois qui vient
il nous faut nous mobiliser nous
mobiliser pour nos aînés et les plus
fragiles et nous mobiliser pour nos
enfants pour les protéger et leur
permettre de continuer à apprendre et
leur préparer le pays et le continent le
monde auquel ils ont droit
nous mobiliser parce que le succès de ce
mois d'avril et de cette stratégie
dépend de chacun d'entre nous de notre
esprit de responsabilité
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons rebâtir ce
chemin d'espoir celui qui nous permettra
de retrouver progressivement une vie
normale celui qui nous permettra aussi
de tirer ensemble toutes les leçons de
cette épreuve mais nous tiendrons une
et déterminé vive la république et vive
la france
bon son
bienvenue sur le site du figaro
bienvenue dans le grand studio du figaro
on est avec vous pour décrypter
débriefer ces annonces des manuels
macron 24 minutes exactement
d'allocutions qui ont été écoutées avec
attention par les journalistes et les
experts du figaro ce soir dont
christophe devaux qui est avec nous
bonsoir christophe vous êtes historien
des idées politiques professeur à
sciences po est également spécialiste de
rhétorique politique et ce soit on va
analyser ce qu'a dit est ce que n'a pas
dit le président de la république et
comment le président de la république a
annoncé des mesures des mesures pour
l'essentiel sanitaires bien entendu
qu'on va également décrypté commenté
avec avec vous cyril van lerberghe du
service science du figaro et vous voyez
que l'accueil des faits relativement à
la au prestige de votre fonction et de
l'ex du travail sans relâche que vous
fournissez depuis un an pour les
lecteurs du figaro puis on est en direct
également avec marc landré qui est par
skype et qui le chef du service économie
du figaro qui va également décrypté les
mesures économiques qui sont annoncés
confirment et plus exactement par le
président de la république bonsoir
marque vous nous posez vos questions
sont transmises et je les consulte en
direct sur le player du figaro également
sur lequel le site sur le compte youtube
du figaro je salue notamment jean paul
antoine kriss kross
agathe et même un internaute qui se fait
surnommer neurones bonsoir à tous
bienvenue sur le site du figaro on prend
de tout de suite vos commentaires qu'est
ce que c'est cette tenue mais écoutez
c'est une tenue un petit peu plus
décontracté que d'habitude parce que
justement on essaye de recevront
trousses et les manches pour comprendre
ce que le président de la république a
annoncé cyril ce soir quand même la
mesure forte de l'annnonce du président
de la république c'est que les mesures
qui étaient en vigueur dans 19
départements sont étendues à partir de
ce week-end à l'ensemble du territoire
avec une mention spéciale pour les
écoles alors oui ça c'est là la grande
nouvelle et c'est aussi là c'est un peu
surprenant c'est que depuis deux
semaines on voit qu'on a une mesure qui
marche pas dans 19 départements qui ne
suffit pas à freiner l'épidémie on
l'appliqué au pays entier donc c'est la
première surprise
l'autre chose après en fait je pense que
emmanuel macron activer le dernier
levier qui lui reste qu'en avec des
français qui n'ont pas envie de se
confiner ces les écoles les écoles on
estime que c'est un tiers des
contaminations en france on n'a pas fait
de tests au début de l'épidémie nous
qu'on pensait que le virus circule et
pas chez les enfants ils n'ont pas de
symptômes ils sont jeunes ils sont en
bonne santé ils seront pas touchés par
le virus
en fait ils sont aussi des relais qui
transmettent et tient introduisent les
virus dans les familles et qui passent
de génération en génération que donc
l'école c'est un levier vraiment
important d'un point de vue
d'épidémiologie pour freiner la
propagation du virus a fait ses choix je
pense au fait c'était le dernier levier
qui restait à emmanuel macron c'est de
jouer sur les écoles sans dire qu'il est
fermé on prolonge les vacances c'est pas
c'est pas bête le fait que toutes les
vacances ou en même temps et qui est pas
de déplacement ben voilà on
on a un système qui est finalement
égalitaire mais qui va être équipe être
dur parce que c'est les vacances on
bouge pas ou on est avec les enfants
mais on peut espérer un petit effet de
ce côté là sur l'effet d'extension du
confinement faux confinement à tout pays
je suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment
très efficace par rapport à un
confinement qui était enfin qu'un
couvre-feu à 19 heures voilà qui était
déjà plus efficace pour freiner
l'épidémie
alors justement on va y revenir
peut-être dans cette danse est certes le
débrief président de la république a
notamment vanté les mesures qu'il a
prises qui ont été prises
il aurait fuit cas cités on va voir
juste avec vous si c'est si c'est
vraiment le cas
peut-être un commentaire christophe de
vogue vous êtes professeur les étudiants
sont autorisés dit le président de la
république à venir mais simplement
qu'une fois parce par semaine ç'a un
impact également sur l'ensemble de
l'éducation nationale sur sur tout le
système éducatif
vous qui êtes professeur est ce que vous
pensez que cette mesure peut être bien
accueilli par vos collègues par la
communauté éducative
écoutez déjà nous nous étions en
confinement si j'ose dire puisque nous
étions déjà intégralement en télétravail
il ya pour une raison très simple c'est
que d'une part il y avait déjà des
mesures de précaution sur les campus
mais aussi parce qu'il y a nous avons
beaucoup d'étudiants étrangers à
sciences po donc beaucoup ne sont pas
sur place
donc je pense que ça va pas changer
grand chose pour les universités je
crois que c'est pas mal d'avoir laissé
quand même cette journée qui peut être
important symboliquement j'irai pour les
étudiants pour quand même qu'ils aient
l'impression de vivre une vie
universitaire mais je crois que c'est
pas la mesure phare de ce qui a été
annoncé par par le président je voudrais
juste posé une question en fait à mes
deux co partenaires on peut dire c'est
la question de oui sans doute
on va on va pas bouger sauf pendant le
week-end de pâques donc il peut pas il
pourrait bien y avoir puisqu'il ya après
il ya plus de cours puisqu'on est en
zoom ou hans caspar skype ou etc ou en
mission ce qu'on voudra et comme il n'y
aura plus de cours à partir de la
semaine prochaine si j'ai bien compris
quand même beaucoup de gens peuvent
partir faire comme dans le premier
confinement un confinement plus aux
verts est-ce que j'ai bien compris
oui ça c'est vrai s'avère que les gens
vont avoir la portée de partir ce
week-end et quelque part c'est pas une
mauvaise chose du point de vue du
contrôle de l'épidémie d'avoir la voir
les villes qui se vide un petit peu
réponse à un internaute qui justement
s'emporte contre les parisiens qui ont
contaminé la bretagne qui risque de le
faire alors de fait à partir de ce
week-end alors quand on est en province
c'est sûr c'est pas agréable de voir les
parisiens débarquent et c'est pas
c'est un virus mais voilà c'est plus je
pense ou plus large que d'elle que
l'épidémie mais le d'un point de vue
d'une circulation du virus à voir une
des villes où il ya moins de densité de
population - déjà - de risque d'
échanges entre les gens et bien c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle donc assez
cynique ce que vous êtes en train de
dire c'est que ça ça peut provoquer une
déconcentration par exemple notamment en
ile-de-france qui nous lie est le plus
grand de la plus grande densité en
france oui alors c'est la région la plus
grosse activité densité et oui où
l'épidémie est la plus grave en ce
moment parce qu'on a on a dépassé le
nord et b pack a donc oui face et c'est
sûr que le symbole est pas joli à voir
de voir les riches par les instructions
les moyens d'avoir une maison de
campagne qui va être un peu attaqué là
dessus par par la gauche notamment c'est
possible alors on va peut-être également
voir avec marc landré qui alors a du
talent nous demande si on aura des off
des oeufs en chocolat apparemment oui
puisque ce à partir donc de samedi soir
que ces mesures entrent en vigueur
marc le président de la république donc
à confirmer que les mesures qui
accompagne toute une série d'acteurs
économiques vont perdurer la question
que j'ai envie de vous poser c'est que
jusqu'à quand la france peut se
permettre de d'avoir ce dispositif
jusqu'à temps que le président leur a
décidé c'est à dire que maintient
économiquement le pays sous perfusion
depuis un an alors plus ou moins
fortement les doses varie en fonction de
la situation sanitaire et de la
nécessaire maîtrise de la propagation de
l'épidémie
mais à partir du moment où on emprunte à
rien à pas cher sur les marchés
financiers pour s'endetter
on peut continuer je dirais quasiment
théoriquement à du tam aeternam
en tout cas le temps que
le pays se remette d'aplomb et soit
capable de revivre normalement
donc ça veut dire que pour répondre
concrètement à votre question à court
terme jusqu'à temps que on est une
immunité collective en matière de
vaccination pour permettre de baisser la
propagation du virus et de la rendre
quasiment anecdotique c'est des fameux
5000 contamination jours qu'on visait
après la fin du second confinement à
l'automne et donc ça ça arrivera une
fois plus grande majorité de la
population a été vaccinée
donc c'est d'ici la fin de l'été ou au
plus tôt au début de l'automne selon les
degrés de livraison les délais de
livraison des différents vaccins
donc tant que les marchés financiers
n'explose pas et qu'on peut se
refinancer à très bas coût voire à coût
négatif et jusqu'à temps qu'on ait une
immunité collective qui nous protège et
qui nous permettent de revivre à peu
près normalement comme avant le
département de la réunion est il
concerné par la fermeture des écoles nos
demandes sont internautes havre et
lloris et la france métropolitaine qui
est conseil qui ont concerné et
simplement l
c'est ce que j'ai compris oui oui c'est
ce que a annoncé effectivement le
président disant une extension à la
france métropolitaine
on va vérifier dans l'est dans les
dépêches si on reprend les mesures vous
continuez à commenter à nous poser vos
questions dès que si on a des réponses
qu'on la donne tout de suite sinon on la
cherche
on tâche de le faire en tous les cas et
madame macron première déclaration dit
au début de son intervention
nous voyons et nous verrons le bout du
tunnel
est ce que il est vraisemblable que nous
puissions voir le bout du tunnel
regard l'évolution de l'épidémie et de
l'évolution des variants aujourd'hui
cette année oui oui on a on a
enfin une vaccination qui accélère et
qui accélère très fortement donc on a on
a plus d'écart entre les livraisons et
les injections
donc on vaccine à flux tendu et en été
on a eu des journées à plus de 330
milles injection début de semaine on est
on est vraiment sur un rythme qui va
permettre d'atteindre si les livraisons
sur le tiennent le coup en fait ça va
dépendre des laboratoires mais avec
l'arrivée des vaccins de johnson johnson
a en avril
on va arriver avec la fin du tc un
objectif vraiment crédible à voir tous
les français vaccinés et donc d'avoir
une ralentir très fortement la
circulation du virus
de plus on aura plus de cas graves parce
que ces vaccins sont vraiment efficaces
pour empêcher les cas graves de la
maladie donc on aura des hôpitaux qui
vont se se vide et on aura plus de
malades eu un virus dans la transmission
sera fortement ralenti et il restera
alors une inconnue c'est celle des
variants le monde sait que les vaccins
notamment sur astrazeneca est un peu
moins efficace contre le vaillant sud
africain et vins brésiliens donc là est
ce que ces variants vous me progressé
par rapport aux variants anglais ont
c'est l'inconnu en fait mais là encore
on a une chance incroyable c'est qu'on a
des tic nos deux vaccins génial avec le
vaccin arn hon moderna et 13h ont déjà
reprogrammés lors leur premier vaccin
pour s'adapter aux variants donc on va
on vendra avant la fin de l'année des
vaccins avec des troisième dose de
rappel pour être protégés contre tous
les variants donc vous est précis on
chope des vaccins oui oui je suis tu je
suis un vrai fan au un vrai fan des
excès des vaccins arn parmi les mesures
qui sont annoncées
je reviens vers vous cyril
le nombre de places pour l'instant on
voit pas le bout du tunnel dans les
hôpitaux et en particulier en
réanimation
est-ce qu'on peut justement décrypter ce
qui est annoncé autour du déplace autour
des lits en réanimation
actuellement si nos informations sont
bonnes il ya aux alentours de 5 ml est
là le président parle de d'ouvrir
jusqu'à dix mille cas 10000 en fait en
fait le message fri dire s'est il est en
fait il est conscient que les mesures
qu'il a acquis l'annoncent vont pas
inversée brutalement la courbe des
contaminations
donc on va se retrouver avec un affluent
à l'hôpital qui va être qu'il va
poursuivre donc il prévoit en fait que
la situation va s'aggraver à l'hôpital
et est donc on va on va atteindre déjà
il a parlé de sept mille lits comme
premier objectif c'est le pic de la
première vague
donc on les imagine qu'il estime vous
rythme actuel on peut l'atteindre il dit
qu'on les a maintenant des 17000 oui
mais en fait ils risquent d'être remplis
en fait cette ligne donc c'est il va y
avoir 10 va y avoir des malades ils
veulent avoir donc des malades grade qui
vont continuer à rêver et en gros il dit
outre aignan il faut que vous tenez le
coup il ya nos clients qui aura pas
d'amélioration très franche et les
malades vont arriver va falloir les
soigner donc ça c'est un premier signal
est en fait c'est pour moi c'est presque
la critique principale c'est quand il
dit le 18 mars nous avons pris des
mesures supplémentaires pour éviter le
risque que de perdre le contrôle avec
l'épidémie moi j'ai peur que le contrôle
ils soient déjà perdu en fait le
gouvernement n'a plus l'intention de
casser la courbe de l'épidémie
on est juste dans des stratégies de
freinage éviter que ça s'enflamme éviter
que ce soit uniquement une progression
exponentielle comme on l'a connu en
novembre ou encore pire en mars 2020
donc on est on est sur une stratégie de
il faut gagner du temps c'est une course
de vitesse parce que d'un côté on a on a
des facteurs très positifs qui sont qui
vont ralentir la croissance de
l'épidémie qui sont l'immunité
collective on a de plus en plus de gens
qui ont été malades
on a l'immunité qui acquise par les
vaccins donc ça progresse vite donc déjà
8 millions de personnes qui ont déjà une
première dose tout ça c'est un troisième
facteur qui lui difficile à modéliser
mais qui va être important c'est l'effet
de la météo
malheureusement la météo pour la semaine
prochaine n'est pas bonne
faire une vague de froid qu'a lancé sur
la france dont que d'un point de vue
épidémiologique pas terrible mais on
peut penser qu'avec le printemps tout ça
c'est des facteurs qui vont qui vont
ralentir l'épidémie donc c'est une
course de vitesse pour dire il faut
tenir à l'hôpital les sept mille lits
qui sont déjà prêts je moi je crains
qu'ils ne soient qu'ils soient occupés
dans les semaines qui viennent
et voilà donc c'est une stratégie
vraiment de freiner freinage pour gagner
du temps et un esprit que les facteurs
positifs vont finir par atténuer cette
épidémie à l'or parmi des mesures fortes
on le disait tout à l'heure et je
réponds à une question du go sur youtube
que saluer tous ceux qui nous suivent en
ce moment sur youtube qui nous demande
de faire un point sur les écoles alors
que va-t-il se passer dans les écoles et
bien les écoles sont fermées à partir de
ce week end une semaine de cours en
rendit essentielle
et puis ensuite pour toute la france il
n'y a pas la zone à b et c
comme c'est traditionnellement le cas
pour les zones de printemps il n'y a
qu'une seule et même zone
sur toute la france métropolitaine ça
c'est une autre réponse à d'autres
internautes qui nous demande quand est
il de la polynésie on a tant parlé d
outre-mer là pour l'instant s'étaient
concentrées sur la france métropolitaine
donc une seule zone avec des vacances
qui vont commencer dès la fin de la
semaine prochaine
et qui c'est qui s'arrêteront pour
qu'ils s'arrêteront à au début de la
semaine du 26 avril avec sept encore une
semaine en distance yale et puis la
possibilité de revenir en présentiel
à partir du lundi 3 mai prochain avec
des jauges c'est une
mesures fortes marc landré sas a des
implications ça des implications sur
l'organisation pour le travail les
arrêts maladie et les arrêts en tous les
cas d arrêt de travail de choses
différentes se multiplient en ce moment
ils disons que à partir du moment où
vous avez une multiplication par trois
du nombre de classes qu'on était fermé
depuis le début de la semaine
forcément vous avez des parents qui
récupère à la maison des enfants qu'ils
peuvent fait accueillis dans le système
scolaire et donc ils peuvent pas télé
travailler normalement ou travailler
tout court
donc les arrêts maladie sont justement
prévu comme cela depuis le début de la
crise pour permettre aux parents qu'ils
récupèrent leurs enfants pour les garder
à domicile de pouvoir être indemnisées
le temps où ils font soit la classe soit
ils gèrent leurs enfants donc oui ça
s'est multiplié depuis le début de la
semaine
parce qu'on est une multiplication de
fermetures de classes et ça va
évidemment se multiplier dans la semaine
prochaine puisque là c'est pas une
multiplication des formes d'aidé des
classes fermées qu'on va avoir c'est
toutes les classes qui vont être fermés
et donc avec des parents qui ne pourront
pas à télétravailler qui devront gérer
et faire la classe à leurs enfants
du moins les garder pendant ce temps là
et donc on va avoir des arrêts maladies
qui vont se démultiplier mais le
président a été très clair le président
macron a bien dit que il demandait à
l'assurance maladie qui gère les arrêts
maladie pour les parents qui doivent
gérer leurs enfants de jouer le jeu et
les accorder systématiquement d'ailleurs
il suffit de faire une auto déclaration
sur le site de l'assurance maladie qui
le fait très bien et très vite et ça
c'est uniquement lorsque le télétravail
à bhl n'est pas possible
petit bémol ou petites nuances et
lorsque vous êtes deux et que vous tous
les deux vous êtes à domicile le
bénéfice de la révéla dit ne concerne
qu'un seul des deux parents et non les
deux deux questions se sont posées par
les internautes sur youtube
ça défile vite alors j'essaie de les
retrouver la première internautes qui ne
demandent qu en est il du secteur du btp
mais le btp par définition il put delà
du mal à télétravailler donc moi je sais
pas macro sur des maisons et des
bâtiments à domicile c'est compliqué
donc eux ils sont pas concernés qu'en
est il facilite pas concerné par don pas
le télétravail en revanche ils sont
concernés s'ils ne peuvent pas aller sur
un chantier pour pouvoir garder leurs
enfants à domicile
évidemment
et qu'en est-il également pour les
livres pour les librairies jusqu'à
présent elle était encore ouverte
alors la liste de la liste des magasins
autorisés à ouverture ne change pas
c'est à dire que l'on va avoir une
extension des dendé des règles en
vigueur dans 19 départements sur
l'ensemble du territoire et les règles
qui étaient en vigueur dans ces dix neuf
départements sont étendues à l'ensemble
du territoire et donc les magasins qui
étaient autorisés à ouvrir dans ses 19
départements seront autorisés à ouvrir
par dans l'est dans le sens du
territoire et donc par défaut ou par
l'absurde ce qui était interdit
d'ouverture bas seront interdits
l'ouverture demain dessous lançons des
territoires et comme les libraires et
est considéré maintenant comme un comme
des boutiques essentiels comme les
disquaires comme les fleuristes comme
les coiffeurs et bien ils pourront le
rester poste week-end de pâques lorsque
le confinement sera étendu à l'ensemble
dû territoire métropolitain d'énormément
de question également merci marc autour
de la notion de des frontières pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de mesures
supplémentaires qui ont été prises aux
frontières en tous les cas si ça a été
dit ça m'a échappé est ce que vous avez
entendu quelque chose sur cinq reste un
grand je n'ai rien entendu sur ça j'ai
entendu sur d'autres choses on y viendra
peut-être non sur les frontières mais à
priori le contrôle est déjà en place
depuis depuis qu'elles luttent depuis
janvier donc qu'on va voir ce qui ce
qu'il en est un internaute disait alors
j'ose pas on n'a pas peut-être pas pu
vérifier mais que en tout cas les vols
vers l'afrique du sud ou le brésil
quand même à l'origine de deux à deux
variants eux sont toujours autorisés
actuellement témoignages non monsieur je
ne sais pas sur les cas particulier du
brésil et l'afrique du sud mais la
france est plutôt un foyer de l'épidémie
contre laquelle d'autres pays cherchent
à se protéger donc c'est que dans
l'autre sens que les variants brésilien
neymar le sud africain ils sont déjà
présents et ils songent à présent son
propre territoire en faible proportion
ils sont un peu moins contagieux que par
les anglais donc il se propage pas on un
peu de chance on a su une question un
mot qui revient quand même beaucoup
dans l'est dans les commentaires en ce
moment c'est le mot confinement et c'est
un mot qui n'a pas été prononcée est ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est mais mona de
macron a essayé de vendre l'art d'un
nouveau confinement sans en prononcer le
mot est un mot qui est devenu tabou
donc est ce qu'on aura la chose pas
vraiment parce que si je comprends bien
le régime des attestations va être quand
même très allégée savons maintenant qui
est très étrange
au delà ce 10 km il faut voilà vous
fassiez une attestation si vous allez de
railler ou donc c'est fini les
attestations pour aller faire ses
courses se sont élevées à son jogging à
tout ce qui était quand même
terriblement infantilisant et je dirais
inquiétant dans le premier confinement
mais ce que je remarque c'est que le
confinement n'est plus prononcée dans le
cas de la france payée dans le cas de
l'allemagne
alors ça c'est quand même ça fait un
petit peu sourire parce que l'allemagne
n'a jamais été confinés c'est à dire que
si on appelle confinement le fait que
les gens soient obligés de rester chez
eux
les allemands n'ont jamais été contre
confiné j'en connais suffisamment ils
ont toujours eu le droit de sortir quand
il nous l'est ils ont le droit de faire
du sport sans demander l'autorisation à
personne et surtout pas eux mêmes donc
ce qu'il ya eu en main c'est une
fermeture des commerces sont
essentielles et des écoles donc le mot
confinement est devenu tabou ce qui est
amusant c'est que la france qui était un
modèle de confinement maintenant quand
se considèrent le mot n'est plus
possible pour le président puisqu'il y a
finalement il en a fait une sorte de
voile à deux totems de quelque chose qui
est qui qui ne peut plus être prononcée
devant devant le peuple
voilà c'est une c'est un discours qui
rhétoriquement est très claire dans
l'autojustification est très longue
d'ailleurs puisque c'est un discours
peut-être quand même rappeler que c'est
un discours que quand même encore une
fois très long trop long d'1 24 minutes
je rappelle que les discours de crise le
principe d'un discours de crise c'est
qu'il soit bref 24 minutes où le
président très bien très brillamment
comme toujours rentrer dans une nombre
de cas particuliers c'est ça lui donnait
le calendrier des écoles hes à lui
donner de calendrier de la vaccination
de préciser les âges les comorbidités
enfin peut-être qu'on pourrait avoir un
peu de sous traitance là dessus il ya
quand même un ministre de la santé qui
connaît ses sujets
et au risque de perdre l'essentiel du
message c'est à dire que les gens vous
pose des questions de sur les détails
mais moi je me sens toujours pas une
direction bien clair au niveau politique
et il me semble que c'est quand même au
président sinon à qui d'autre de la
donner vous avez été aperçu vous une
autre question la même chose mais je
pose des questions je fends vos
commentaires vous continuez de réagir
flight me dit je suis expatrié nous
serons de retour en juin seront nous
autoriser à entrer en france ce qui
serait intéressant c'est que vous nous
disiez d'où vous d'où vous venez et doux
où vous êtes actuellement expatriés
qu'est-ce qu'on peut donner comme
réponse à cet internaute ciel en général
oui les experts peuvent rentrer en
france recovery donc un autre un autre
internaute qui s'appelle robin qu'on
salue le confinement de mars nous dit il
n'a pas marché celui d'octobre n'a pas
marché pourquoi recommencer je suis pas
d'accord sur les deux premières
affirmations les deux c2 confinement ont
été très efficaces en quels termes ils
ont été bas ils ont ils ont arrêté la
transmission du virus
ils ont réduit le nombre
d'hospitalisations ils ont fait chuter
la mortalité à chaque fois chacun on a
vu on a vu où on prenait confirmant que
moi deuxième on a vu au bout de 9 10
jours un début d'efficacité et là on est
on est à deux semaines après les mesures
déjà annoncées début mars et on n'a pas
de on n'a pas de signes d'efficacité de
l'est troisième mesure appliquée donc
donc donc les données deux premiers
confinement ont été très efficaces ils
ont été dures mais ont porté leurs
fruits
enfin ils ont joué leur rôle le
président disait emmanuel macron 10 et
le virus circule mais pas plus
qu'ailleurs avec eux pendant l'école le
virus circule mais pas plus qu'ailleurs
vrai faux ça c'est assez vrai il circule
pas plus mais c'est une des voix les
plus fréquentes pour l'introduction dû
virus dans un foyer ou une famille
certes une fois qu'un enfant est malade
qui vit avec ses parents avec ses frères
et soeurs c'est souvent par une
contamination à l'école que le virus se
rend dans un foyer donc c'est un vrai
problème
on va répondre également a dit adieu à
durtal à qui se plaint qu'on ne réponde
pas à sa question alors là parmi les
questions qui nous posent sur ce qui
fait beaucoup de commentaires où elle
fait beaucoup de commentaires si on ne
vaccine pas plus c'est pour la simple
raison qu'on ne peut pas aller plus vite
dans les conditions actuelles c'est
effectivement le cas
et sur ce point là emmanuel macron est
revenu en donnant un
calendrier et en affichant certaines
promesses que là aussi on peut le croire
oui oui oui
en fait on a emmené un démarrage de la
vaccination en france fin décembre qui
était une catastrophe qui dépasse qu'une
blague avec maureen en retraite s'en
souvient et heureusement on a quand même
réussi à inverser la tendance et on l'a
on vaccine au fur à mesure que les deux
arrivent donc le vrai facteur qui limite
la vaccination france aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le manque de bras pour faire
des piqûres
c'est vraiment le rythme d'arrivée des
doses et les livres isu par les
laboratoires il a ce qu'on voit en photo
en avril en avril on va avoir une forte
accélération des livraisons donc avec
les ce thème qui mise en place avec les
centres de vaccination le plus dangereux
à part les 1700 centre dans toute la
france on a avec des gros vaccinodromes
la com au stade de france au vélodrome à
marseille on va pas faire une robe qu'on
pouvait pas ouvrir ce qui est passé de
doses pour l'instant le sacerdoce
ouvrira le prochain arrêt il vous la
semaine prochaine
oui parce que d'importants c'est
véritablement la patte du président dans
cette affaire c'est quand même lui qui a
imposé la femme de scolaires
l'accélération de la vaccination si ça
c'est pas du tout le monde médical ni
les autorités de santé c'est quand même
lui qui a imposé sa et c'est lui qui
s'est engagé sur cette question de
l'approvisionnement des vaccins tant au
niveau français et qu'au niveau européen
et là il faut reconnaître et je crois
qu'il essayait de jouer quand même cet
avantage clairement politiquement aussi
c'est à dire de ce qu'ils aimeraient
bien je crois sentir ces êtres monsieur
monsieur vaccin peut-être un peu comme
ce que johnson fait johnson l'homme
politique un bal vaccin fernand de terre
et c'est en train de lui réussir
formidablement 6eme de macron pouvait
sortir de la crise en disant je suis
monsieur vaccins et je crois qu'il est
je sentis à la fin qu'il ait joué
beaucoup cette carte marque
cet internaute qui s'appelle flight 94
et qui est un internaute récurrents
qu'on retrouve en tout cas c'est souvent
dans la sève du figaro on est content de
retrouver nous dit cette crise qui dure
créé des comportements nuisibles
l'argent n'a plus de valeur la moindre
et il dit
la moindre petite maison aux couronnes
coûte une fortune
est ce que on connaît un petit peu les
les effets ou inattendus justement du
confinement en particulier sur sur
l'économie et en particulier l'économie
autour de paris une étude qui a été
rendu public ce matin par century 21 qui
démontre qu effectivement il ya une
forte progression des demandes
immobilière de maisons dans les
métropoles en dehors des métropoles pour
aller s'exiler un petit peu en dehors
des centres villes mais que ça change
pas fondamentalement la donne sur paris
parce que de toute façon les prix étant
déjà très très élevé il trouve un peu
d'actes peu d'acheteurs
il n'y a pas énormément de changements
si ce n'est une petite baisse de prix
observées à paris mais je vous mets vous
met dans le mille ça reste de toute
façon inaccessible pour vous pour moi
comme pour tout le monde puisque le prix
au mètre carré y dépasse toujours les
11000 euros dans les endroits les moins
chers donc de toutes façons il n'y a pas
eu une incidence immobilière majeure sur
dans la capitale ça c'est certain
en revanche dans les métropoles on voit
qu'il ya une forme de migration qui a
deux il ya une forte demande de maisons
avec jardin en périphérie des métropoles
pour une certaine abandon des centres
villes qui en cas de confinement dur ce
n'est pas ce qu'on va vivre là à partir
de ce lancement du territoire à partir
de samedi soir en cas de confinement dur
les gens veulent pouvoir s'aérer un
petit peu jean-paul j'aimerais bien
avoir votre commentaire marqué celui de
christophe moly c'est évident qu'on crée
une nouvelle dette et que celle ci est
diluée sur la population entière toute
dette tout d'être par définition est
supporté par ceux qui sont vivants et
ceux qui seront vivants demain donc plus
on accroît la dette plus elle se sait
pas qu'elle se dilue en vérité elle
augmente la charge individuelle de
chaque français qui sera amené à la
rembourser demain
alors quand est ce qu'on la remboursera
à quel rythme et à quel prix ça nul ne
le sait aujourd'hui parce que ça
dépendra des conditions au moment où on
aura décidé de la rembourser tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que cette dette
quelles qu'elles soient
quoiqu'elle ait pu écouter ou quoi que
la crise ait pu écouter on les
remboursera un jour ou l'autre
ce soit dans dix ans ou que ce soit au
bout du bout avant l'explosion de la
planète puisque de manière perpétuelle
les cadres ce désir d'être à jamais et
donc on continuera à payer les emprunts
qu'on aura contracté pour rembourser les
dettes passées donc cette dette
on l'appellera on l'appellera jusqu'à la
fin de nos jours chacun c'est une dette
un peu c'est vrai perpétuelle mais qui
quand même chaque année représentera
quelques dizaines de milliards d'euros
et de plus en plus 2 milliards d'euros
même si les taux d'intérêt sont bas
je ne suis pas ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils
le resteront éternellement il peut y
avoir aussi des on voit des phénomènes
de bulles je parle sous le contrôle de
marc landré voix des fans de bulles qui
se produisent
on voit des problèmes de d'acteurs
financiers américains en difficulté il
n'est pas sain il n'est pas certain que
les taux d'intérêt restent éternellement
aussi favorable francisque nous demande
nous dit je suis prêtre et j'aimerais
savoir si les rassemblements entre
guillemets concerne aussi les messes
apparemment également qu'on n'en a pas
parlé même s'il était rentré dans pas
mal de détails mais il n'a pas pas être
ça les cérémonies de pâques pour
l'instant ne sont pas en disant non je
vois ce qu'ils ne touchent pas du tout
occulté
enfin il a évoqué il avait pris part
familiales voilà qu'il ya autour des
fêtes de balle parler il a dit des
cultes je sais que c'est important et il
a invité à une sorte de réserve je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire exactement
peut-être que là on aura des précisions
venant du ministre des cultes
quand il dit que c'est important à ce
qui fait allusion selon vous spécialiste
de rhétorique justement aux polémiques
et au bras de fer qui a eu avec les
cultes à l'automne au moment du deuxième
confinement il ya eu pas mal de
problèmes avec les cultes sous la
présidence macron il ya eu en effet les
questions de confinement il ya eu toute
la question qui va ressortir un jour ou
l'autre des obsèques des cérémonies le
fait de ne pas pouvoir accompagner aussi
bien d'ailleurs j'irai à l'église qu'à
l'hôpital
et c'est des choses qui sont des
blessures profondes dont on ne parle pas
effectivement le jeu profite parce qu'il
vient ne peuvent pas du livre ii
de l'évêque de nanterre qui s'est
beaucoup il s'est beaucoup battu l'ès
beaucoup beaucoup là dessus monseigneur
et ce sont des choses rouge et voilà
entre anthropologiquement forte qui est
mon avis peuvent refaire surface par
exemple au moment de la campagne
présidentielle il ya eu d'autre part
d'autres enjeux avec les cultes
notamment vous avez la loi sur le
séparatisme qui n'a pas plu évidemment à
certains cercles de l'islam mais qui n'a
pas plu non plus à certains cercles
catholiques et juifs on va on va rester
sur la question du confinement pour pour
l'instant pourquoi les commerces de
restauration rapide sont ouverts nous
demande alizés alors que les restaurants
les restaurants traditionnels sont
fermés si cette chose cette chose
pareille c'est le le vrai problème c'est
c'est l'acte de manger face à quelqu'un
sans masque
c'est un restaurant c'est un lieu où on
peut pas porter de masque on a la bouche
ouverte et on parle et on est au mans
j'ai donc il reste plus que la vente à
emporter
c'est assez logique malheureusement mais
le marque justement le secteur de la
restauration pour l'instant résiste aux
mesures et il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui s'étonnent d'ailleurs qui n'est
pas plus de protestations de pas plus
disons le mot de révolte au sein du
secteur de la restauration
disons que le secteur de la restauration
qui est fermée administrativement est
aidée financièrement l'état fait tout ce
qui peut ou du moins mais le maximum sur
la table pour essayer de compenser les
stigmates de la fermeture administrative
s'il est dédié le président a en voulant
montrer un horizon de sortie de crise
lors de son allocution il ya une demi
heure a dit qu'il reviendrait
prochainement devant les français pour
fixer les conditions et les dates d'un
retour à la normale notamment pour
l'ensemble des secteurs qui sont fermés
en parlant de mi juin début juillet pour
tout ce qui est culture et restauration
et bar donc ça veut dire que la la
première la grande différence par
rapport il ya donc on a les trois
derniers mois et je parle sous le
contrôle de mon ami cyril c'est la
première fois qu'on re fixe une date
qu'on refixe une échéance qu'on donne un
horizon à tous ces secteurs qui sont
fermés et quand vous les écoutez bien
qu'il comprenne iq ou qu'ils ne
comprennent pas les raisons de la
fermeture de leur fermeture
administrative
c'est ce qu'ils demandaient y demandait
d'avoir un horizon court
ordonne une date une date butoir vers
laquelle pourraient se projeter dans le
cas d'une réouverture là emmanuel macron
le chef suprême le redis ça sera très
probablement aux alentours du début de
l'été
eh ben c'est peut-être lointain c'est
peut-être difficile pour eux parce que
ça fait quand même six mois qu'ils sont
fermés mais au moins ça leur donne un
horizon vers lequel tenir et vers lequel
se projeter c'est pas si mal
alors effectivement vous allez avoir des
révoltes vous avez des gens qui
pensaient qu'il pourrait ouvrir plus tôt
mais quand on voit à quel point il ya
une propagation une accélération de la
propagation du virus
il était totalement illogique et je
dirais quasiment maladive de pouvoir
penser qu'on pourrait rouvrir les
restaurants là où effectivement on voit
que la chaîne de contamination est la
plus importante et la plus probante
mathieu nous pose cette question cet
internat qui fait sur youtube j'ai
trouvé un emploi mais ne peut commencer
mon contrat car réouverture des magasins
en attendant je suis en précarité
existe-t-il des aides gouvernementales
pour tenir jusqu'aux déconfinement
et il ça dépendra sa dépense six sept
personnes à travailler ou pas avant il
pourra bénéficier des aides qui sont
très spontané que le gouvernement va
peut-être réinjecter pour des gens qui
n'avaient pas de contrastes auparavant
et qui donc il n'ya pas de comparatif de
perte de revenus par rapport à une
période antérieure
sinon s'il avait un contrat avant dans
ce cas là il va bénéficier de lettres
classiques qui lui permet de compenser
la baisse de revenus liée à la fermeture
administrative de au chômage partiel
notamment de 2,2 de son restaurant
autres sont d'établissement il faut
savoir que juridiquement les gens qui
étaient prévus d'être embauché peuvent
l'être même s'il met leur là il y aura
une prise en charge de leur salaire qui
sera faite sous forme de chômage partiel
à partir du moment où effectivement ils
ont une antériorité de d'activité avant
l'entrée en vigueur de leur contrat de
travail
c'est ce que la question était transmise
par charlotte bas rayons de nos bruit
que vous allez retrouver maintenant
régulièrement pour justement animer ses
live et on la salue christophe le fait
d'annoncer un calendrier
justement est-ce que c'est pas aussi
d'un point de vue rhétorique enfin tout
cas dans le discours une façon aussi de
faire supporter et de vendre entre
guillemets de ces mesures qui sont quand
même des mesures qui sont de nouveau
restrictive même si ce n'est pas si je
vous ai bien suivi à nouveau confinement
oui c'est je suis tout à fait d'accord à
ce que dit marc landry sur sur le
calendrier de perspectives pour les
commerces c'est une très bonne chose
mais vous remarquerez que c'est le moins
apprécié de tous donc quand je parlais
du calendrier sur toutes les choses je
pense que le président qui est très bon
encore il sait très bien faire ce que
des techno je pense que il a plutôt lui
intérêt à fixer le langage politique
par exemple il aurait pu faire amende
honorable une fois sur une chose pas du
tout faits a toujours pas bon ça c'est
ça il n'y a pas ce qui m'intéresse là
dedans beaucoup ce sera de voir la
réaction est là je peux être que cyril a
une idée la réaction de l'ap-hp parce
que moi je lis quand même ce discours
comme un niet à l'ap-hp vous avez tous
eu tout ce conflit qu'il a eu sur les
médecins 10 ans fermes east car si je re
je parle sur votre compte et niort
médecin qui avait menacé entre les deux
films a agité le spectre de la menace
or fihri ce qu'ils doivent faire
puisqu'on en étant le confinement aux
autres régions
mais ça ça fait si je veux dire une
belle jambe aux journaux php on leur
demande qu'est ce qu'on leur demande
à l'ap-hp d'augmenter leurs capacités de
soins de rire il m'a dit de tenir bon
point barre
et là je pense qu'on va avoir demain
sinon dès ce soir
quelques pleurs dans les chaumières de
l'ap-hp justement oui c'est un point
effectivement qu'on n'a peut-être pas
assez souligné
il y a
l'effort qui est demandé et c'est les
soignants qui sont les premiers
destinataires de ceux de sète de cet
appel il ya quelque chose qu'on comprend
pas depuis le début depuis le début de
l'épidémie depuis le début de la crise
c'est que le nombre de soignants n'a pas
été augmenté et que le nombre même de
place même nom de structure d'une
structure de fortune de structure dédiée
n'est pas été non plus augmentés alors
ah non en fait il n'y a pas eu de yapen
l'effort structurel mais il ya quand
même des initiatives dans tous les
hôpitaux et dans toutes les régions pour
augmenter les capacités cirque e canton
aujourd'hui c'est les hôpitaux tienne
cirque il n'y a pas de malades qui sont
dans les ambulances qui peuvent pas
rentrer et l'hôpital aujourd'hui c'est
quand même grâce à l'organisation et aux
efforts faits dans les hôpitaux pour
pour faire de la place et pour
s'organiser pour accueillir tous les
malades on est avec aujourd'hui 5000
personnes en réanimation que des malades
qu vide
c'est en fait c'est on est on est à 100
% de capacité c'est en fait c'est
considérable en fait on est en temps
normal les livret a sont occupés à 80%
par d'autres malades et là on a une
seule pathologie qu'il convient 19 qui
remplit toute la capacité donc c est
donc comme on n'a pas refusé de malades
c'est là qu'on a déjà fait de la place
on a déjà fait quelques pas refermées
délit qu'étaient me conseillait comme
moi essentiel pour prendre les
infirmiers prend les aides soignants et
les médecins aussi qui se
reconvertissent pour faire de l'arrière
deux dernières questions
première question à marc landré
emmanuel macron dit que le télétravail a
montré son efficacité
vrai faux ouais vrai vrai vrai cirque on
sait très bien que le télétravail réduit
de plus de 30% la possibilité la
probabilité le risque d'être des trappes
et le virus donc tout journée en
télétravail pour quelqu'un qui peut
aller travailler parce que je rappelle
que tous les salariés où tous les actifs
ne peuvent pas télétravail et vous
parlais tout à l'heure vincent des gens
du bâtiment les gens du bâtiment ils
peuvent pas aller travailler
les jeux d'hier et les
les fabricants de piscines ils peuvent
pas télétravail et les conducteurs
d'avion ils peuvent pas aller travailler
on estime qu' à peu près 40 % des
salariés français qui ont une ou des
fonctions qui sont télétravail a donc ça
limite le champ mais in fine et tout
journée télétravail et qui donc qui
évite des déplacements qui évite de
multiplier les contacts sociaux et une
chance puisque c'est une probabilité
en plus de ne pas attraper le virus est
là on l'a vu très concrètement que ça
réduit de 30% la probité d'un rappel
virus y ont fait du chômage du
télétravail partiellement
ici c'est du télétravail à complet on
passe à plus de 50% le risque de ne pas
attraper le virus est ce que j'ai pas
entendu le président dire que le
télétravail devient obligatoire quand il
est possible bien suivi peux pas te pas
il doit pas dire il n'a pas dit ce que
juridiquement juridiquement on ne peut
pas le gouvernement ne peut pas rendre
le crédit travail obligatoire il ne peut
que de ce que fait impression on verra
était la chose qui risque une entreprise
c'est pas de ne pas développer le
télétravail c'est de ne pas tout mettre
en oeuvre pour garantir la sécurité et
la santé de ses salariés
le télétravail est un moyen de garantir
cette sécurité pas une fin en soi et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on ne peut pas
rendre le travail obligatoire et c'est
pour ça que le gouvernement dit qu'il va
systématiser et renforcer les contrôles
en entreprise pour faire en sorte que le
télétravail soit bien utilisé ou
développer quand il peut l'être mais un
inspecteur du travail ne peut pas
sanctionner une entreprise qui le
développe pas le télétravail elle peut
la mettre en demeure et apple porter le
problème en justice si jamais elle se
rend compte qu'il ya une mise en danger
des salariés de l'entreprise
c'est uniquement là dessus et quand vous
regardez le ministère du travail ce soir
a fait une communication pour dire que
le protocole sanitaire en entreprise ne
changeait pas entre avant et après le
week-end prochain où on va avoir un
conflit
qui veut être généralisé à l'ensemble du
territoire ça veut dire que 1
lorsqu'on peut télétravail et doigté les
travaillées est deux on doit pouvoir
revenir également une journée par
semaine sur le lieu de travail si on
estime que spécifiquement
psychologiquement médicalement
sanitairement on a besoin d'une soupape
et de quitter l'endroit où on
télétravail pour revenir voir ses
collègues ou pour revenir sur son lieu
de travail habituel donc en vérité ça ne
change absolument rien les règles
qu'elle est en vigueur avant ce soir
resteront en vigueur demain
à ceci près que ça sera étendu à
l'ensemble du territoire mais y'aura pas
plus d'obligation de télétravail et qui
en avait hier une question d'ailleurs
laquelle on va répondre tout de suite
soldats des ald et qu'est-il prévu pour
les infirmières parents d'enfants en
crèches ou écoles maternelles et bien le
président arrive enel macron a annoncé
que pour les enfants de ces personnels
là les écoles les crèches restée ouverte
un dernier point sur les vaccins
emmanuel macron semblait un peu
claironné ce soir un calendrier sur
triomphal et triomphant sur la
possibilité de vaccination
ça reste quand même encore très lent si
on prend quand même les dates on la
perspective c'est la fin de l'été et ça
avance assez assez longtemps alors en
fait oui en fait c'est assez trompeur
pour la population en général ça va
aller ça valait lentement et pour les
populations les plus à risques les plus
âgés ça va quand même assez vite on a
aujourd'hui 60%
des plus de 75 ans qui est vraiment la
catégorie qui la plus à risque avec le
co vide qui est qui a déjà eu une dose
du vaccin donc à une protection qui est
pas parfaite mais qui est déjà serré
elle est dans cette classe d'âge ça va
assez vite en fait donc je moi je suis
plutôt optimiste en fait je on voit déjà
les faits la vaccination ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui il n'ya plus presque plus de
mort du co vite dans les ehpad
c'est quand même c'était c'était plus
d'un tiers des glissements maintenant
dans les ehpad et les problèmes
psychologiques
il est urgent et il est urgent d'ouvrir
les ehpad et de rétablir les visites
parce que la vaccination est active et
efficace donc c'est vrai que c'est
important c'est urgent donc on voit déjà
cet effet là on voit que la mortalité a
très fortement baissé
j'ai chez les plus de 80 ans donc les
signes sont là que cette efficacité du
vaccin elle va elle va dans les semaines
qui viennent ça va ça va jouer ça va
être que des effets positifs
merci beaucoup merci christophe d'être
venu également commenté et décrypter ce
discours merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis désolé on n'a pas pu répondre à
toutes les questions flight vous nous
demandez des mesures fiscales sont elles
prévues pour les salariés qui
télétravaillent via je vous recommande
de vous reporter aux à la verticale
économie du figaro économie qui est
juste à clé de ce player sur le site du
figaro où vous aurez les réponses à ces
questions merci beaucoup cyril et on
recommande un grand récit à paraître
dans le figaro dans l'édition papier du
figaro donc apparaître en pdf dans les
heures qui viennent qui est déjà
également sur le sur le site sur comment
on a essayé d'éviter le variant anglais
sans pouvoir y parvenir et c'est un
grand récit passionnant qui est racontée
par le service science et on retrouve
toutes les toutes les annonces des mails
macron vous les avez dans le chat vous
les avez également dans l'édition papier
toutes les conséquences que cela en
matière politique en matière économique
en matière et surtout scolaire puisque
je vous le rappelle c'est la mesure
principale annoncé ce soir d'extension
du confinement au l'ensemble l'extension
pardon des mesures de freinage puisqu'il
faut pas dire le mans confinement autres
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
et la fermeture physique des classes à
partir de ce week-end avec une semaine
en distance yale puis ensuite vacances
obligatoires pour l'ensemble de la
france et une reprise une rentrée en
distance yale à partir du 26 avril
prochain avant un une rentrée en
présentiel le 3 mai prochain
merci beaucoup nous avons suivi merci à
l'équipe de régis au tour de maxime
kunis qui a permis de faire ce live avec
vous merci de nous avoir suivis merci
également à emmanuel isaac et à marie
amélie boucher merci marc landré à
bientôt